OF REPUBLICANS PERFORMANCE IN
THE MID-TERMS.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS INCHING TOWARD
THE MAJORITY.
WE STILL THINK THEY'LL GET
THERE.
THEY FLIPPED A VALUABLE HOUSE
SEAT IN OREGON.
THE WINNER OF THAT SEAT WE'LL
HEAR FROM HER NOW.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK PEOPLE WERE TIRED AND
FRUSTRATED OF THE HIGH CRIME
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN OUR BLUE
STATES.
THEY WERE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
INFLATION RISING 8 1/2% IN
OREGON.
NOT BEING ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH
WAGES.
AND THE EDUCATION PROCESS.
PEOPLE WERE FRUSTRATED WITH
THEIR KIDS IN SCHOOL BEING
LOCKED DOWN FOR TOO LONG.
THEY WANTED TO SPEAK UP AND WANT
WORK DONE.
>> Harris: WHAT WORKED FOR
REPUBLICANS IN OREGON?
>> YOU JUST SAW IT.
SHE PROVES AGAIN THAT MESSENGERS
ARE AS IMPORTANT AS MESSAGE.
CANDIDATE QUALITY MANNER.
SHE IS A HIGH QUALITY CANDIDATE.
THEIR FIRST TIME CANDIDATES AND
I HOPE THEY RUN AGAIN.
BUT IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO NOT BEAT
BIDE IN.
WE FAILED TO GET MORE
INDEPENDENTS TO VOTE REPUBLICAN.
USUALLY IN THE MID-TERMS FROM
2006 TO 2018 THE PARTY OUT OF
POWER CARRIED INDEPENDENTS BY
DOUBLE DIGITS AND OVER A
MAJORITY.
THIS TIME DEMOCRATS WON
INDEPENDENTS 49-47.
IF YOU WERE A PRO-CHOICE
INDEPENDENT YOU WERE MORE
MOTIVATED TO VOTE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE SAME
MOTIVATORS FOR CRIME AND
ECONOMY.
LOOKING FORWARD TO 2024.
A TOUGH SENATE MAP FOR
DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS THIS TIME.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, HARRIS, JOE
BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS CAN'T
TELL JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
PLEASE DON'T CAMPAIGN WITH US.
THEY WILL NEED TO BE OUT THERE
FOR THEIR OWN CAMPAIGNS.
SO THEY ARE STUCK -- THE
DEMOCRATS ARE STUCK WITH THEM
AND THEMSELVES MOVING FORWARD.
>> Harris: THE NEXT TIME WE GET
TOGETHER WE'LL TALK ABOUT
GEORGIA.
WE'RE INCHING OUR WAY CLOSER TO
THE RUNOFF.
THAT RACE MATTERS, TOO.
YOU MENTIONED A 50/50
POSSIBILITY FOR REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET THERE AND IT
WOULD BE 51 FOR DEMOCRATS IF YOU
DON'T GET THERE.
WITH HERSCHEL WALKER.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT.
GREA